rector of the White House Situation Room
during the Reagan presidency he
chronicles the function and history of
the room in his new book nerve center
this talk from the Belhaven Country Club
in Alexandria Virginia is 50 minutes
thanks for having me tonight my name is
Mike Vaughn I live in Wayne wood down
the road here and not Merton and I used
to be the director of the White House
Situation Room when I was on active duty
as a naval officer and I have a new book
called in nerve center inside the White
House Situation Room and we're trying to
sell books and Tom Murphy your general
manager invited me to come tonight and
speak to anybody that wanted to come
about the book and answer questions
about the White House Situation Room
we welcome c-span here tonight c-span
book TV and I'll try to keep this brief
and what I'd like to do is just go
through show you some pictures talk a
little bit about what happens in the
White House Situation Room and then at
the end if you have some questions I'd
be happy to take them what you see right
here on the screen is a picture of
George W Bush in the White House
Situation Room just after 9/11 and he
and his advisors are trying to decide
what do we do now how do we retaliate if
we do and that's a common occurrence in
the Situation Room during a crisis or
during a war and in some instances
during peacetime it's a small room no
bigger than your living room 18 feet by
18 feet it's nicely paneled nicely
appointed but it is not the war room
that dr. Strangelove had in the Pentagon
or what you might have seen in some of
the movies it's simply a conference room
where the president can look his
advisors right in the eye and ask them
what should I do
now there's a bunch more around the
conference room okay Joe
the Situation Room is not just a room
it's the president's intelligence center
and it was started in 1961 when Kennedy
wanted more information about what was
going on in the world General Eisenhower
was quite content to get a daily summary
from the State Department CIA the
Pentagon he didn't want to know any
details he left it to his staff
Kennedy's intellect was so great that he
wanted more information so that he could
make better decisions and the only way
to get that information was to get some
communication circuits in the White
House and have the rest of the
government send information to the White
House intelligence reports diplomatic
cables and in order to take advantage of
that information they had to have
someone there 24 hours a day to read it
to separate what was good and what was
hot and what was cold in the beginning
it was run by the president's naval aide
I'll come back to that after Kennedy's
assassination the National Security
Council staff took it over first and
foremost is the president's alert Center
meetings are sort of a third or fourth
priority in the Situation Room it's also
the communication center for the White
House they writes up daily summaries of
world activities and they help during
crises I don't know whether you can see
it down right here at the bottom excuse
me but I got this great quote from Jimmy
Carter and I had to soften it up a
little bit I can tell it here I think I
can tell it to see spin it's just a day
or two before he left office he was
desperately trying to get the hostages
out of Iran and it has been alleged that
the Reagan campaign staff made a deal
with Iran to keep those hostages until
Reagan was inaugurated to deprive that
that triumph from Jimmy Carter in the
director of the White House Situation
Room at that time was a man named Dennis
Chapman and he took the materials up to
the president next to the last morning
of his of his term Carter was at in the
sad state he'd been up for two or three
days trying to negotiate the hostages
really
and he got up and has put his arm around
at his chapman and he said you know
Dennis the White House Situation Room is
the only part of the government that
never let me down I went to Carter and a
Dennis to get permission to use that
quote and they were a little concerned
because it suggested the rest of the
government didn't know what they were
doing so I made this deal with Jimmy
Carter and Dennis Chapman for this quote
right here at the change that the
snippets and okay Joe most news media
representatives and the entertainment
industry believe that the Situation Room
is a bunker buried underneath the South
Lawn and it's not this is the West Wing
of the White House this is the corner
where the chief of staff's office is
this is West executive Avenue that
separates the West Wing from the old
executive office building
now the Eisenhower executive office
building this was painted in 1972 you
can see the Oval Office right here and
these windows right here are part of the
Situation Room complex so on the ground
floor my office was right here I had a
little window box full of geraniums in
the summertime and a little strip of
green grass outside so it's it's not
what they think it is it's technically
the basement but it's the ground floor
and but actually it's a little more than
the Hollywood thinks it is Joe this is
just a stylized drawing of the of the
layout these are the windows that I
spoke to you about just a second ago
right along in here this was my office
my deputies this is the conference room
that everybody focuses on which is right
in the middle the duty officers work
right here
this is a communications area this is an
area that we built in the mid-80s to
provide a video teleconferencing room
which has become a big deal in the White
House and throughout the government it
allows people to get together without
being in the same room
and this is the entrance where you see
people coming and going you've seen them
all week : Powell and Rumsfeld will get
out of their limousines on West exec
Avenue and come in walk down the stairs
to the Situation Room so it's a complex
it's not just a meeting room this is my
old friend Jim Fazio right here who was
the director of the Situation Room
during the the Ford administration this
is Jerry Ford they're talking about the
construction of the pool outdoor pool
Nixon covered over the indoor pool in
the West Wing and it's now the press
theater and in fact there's a trap door
in the middle of the press briefing
theater that goes down to the pool it's
still there
excuse me Ford one at a pool so he
commissioned the construction of an
outdoor pool and it's built right next
to the Situation Room in fact that heads
back behind those two workmen is
directly above the Situation Room and in
fact there was a door built into the
back of the Situation Room where the
Ford and Carter and their families could
walk through the sit room get to the
pool without going across the South Lawn
and being observed by the news media in
their bathing suits and everything Jimmy
Carter came through with his wife one
day and and she asked him will anybody
see us and he said no and they walked
through the sitting room and she had a
towel on her head and a robe on and all
the duty officers stood up when the
president came through and she gave him
the business I thought you said nobody
be down there Amy Carter would run
through with her friends through the sit
room up the stairs into the pool we took
the door out in the in the early 80s
because it just didn't seem a good thing
to have down there but that's where it's
located so now you can sort of
understand where the whole thing is
this is the original White House
Situation Room conference room 1962 it
looks like somebody's basement rec room
in 1962 it was the only room of the
White House furnished in Danish modern I
guarantee you and the reason why it
looks like that was right after the Bay
of Pigs when they built this thing in 30
days they had a little bit of money and
not much time the guy that built that
the president's naval aide Tazewell
Shepard who still lives in Spring Valley
retired Rear Admiral got the Seabees
from Camp David had a little bit of
money and they threw this thing together
in 30 days and that's the way it looked
until the Nixon administration changed
the the interiors of it humble
beginnings obviously but it's come a
little ways since then the man that
built it Tazewell Shepard slide over a
little bit Joe there we go
this man everything that was done in the
White House in those days was a was
largely done the from a physical
standpoint from by one of the military
aides they had fiefdom
the Air Force had the plane the Navy had
the yacht and the Navy mess in the Army
I don't know what they did the Marine
Corps had the helicopters and they sort
of fought with each other about who
should do what and Shepard inherited the
built a white house and inherit it and
his assistant a man named Gary McCabe
ran it for the first two three years in
fact Gary lived in White Oaks right off
a fort Hunt Road and his wife joy Dale
still lives over there and this was a
breakfast that Shepard had in his office
in the Situation Room complex in 62 this
man right here is Jerome Wiesner the
president's science advisor the woman in
the middle of us Judith travail his
personal physician and in captain
Buckley was the White House physician
down there at the end but again it was
we still have meals in the Situation
Room but this was in his office
but the most important part of the
sitting room is its alerting function
screening incoming information telling
the president and his staff about
something that's new or something hot
something breaking something about to
happen these were the duty officers in
1968 during the Tet Offensive in the
Vietnam War and they're working hard to
keep Lyndon Johnson full of information
because he was very demanding and it
hasn't changed much since you don't see
the ashtray as much anymore but it was
the same sort of flurry this is the
original configuration here's a picture
of what it looked like in 1989 better
workstations better computers the
functions are still the same there's
still screening information in this case
what they would do is process incoming
classified information incoming news
information and they would watch CNN on
that monitor right there which which has
become a big deal in the White House
Situation Room over the years one of the
best things I did was buy that clock on
the wall there it's called a gia cron
clock and it tells you where the sun's
shining across the world and if you've
ever been anywhere near the US military
everybody's got one but it's much easier
than trying to use a table to figure out
where the Sun was during and you can see
it's it's it was sometime on one of the
equinoxes because there's about the same
amount of Sun in the northern hemisphere
is there in the southern hemisphere but
today it looks essentially the same
better computers a little different
workstations but these three duty
officers work in 24 hours a day they're
five teams that man the place just as
they did in 68 just better computers
this is the communications area and the
White House communications agency Waka
is a military organization that provides
all the communications support to the
president they man the TV cameras they
have comm centers that follow him around
the world on Air Force One wherever he
goes
there's a waka come suite right behind
him and so we had these technicians
assigned to each watch team to connect
the White House to the vast array of
communications throughout the government
there were special or select
communications within the Situation Room
that are rather sensitive and this man
right here Henry Kissinger used them to
their maximum extent I gave this picture
to him last year and he's square now
he's about as wide as he is tall and he
just couldn't understand how he'd gotten
so big he was the master of back-channel
communications when he started
negotiations with the Chinese to open up
relations with the Chinese he didn't
trust anybody to carry that those
messages to the Chinese except the duty
officers in the White House Situation
Room those only people he trusted he
sent them to New York on the eastern
shuttle with a satchel full of material
are not New York excuse me
yeah to New York to the Chinese mission
in at the UN they'd knock on the door
and the guy the satchel come back to
Washington DC in Kissinger and Al Haig
who told me most of these stories didn't
trust anybody else to do that and it
happened so often the duties duty
officers had to bring their passports in
every time they came to work because
they didn't know where they were going
that night
he also sent him to Paris in his
dialogue with the North Vietnamese
during the secret peace negotiations
same thing fly to Paris
gives him material to dick Walters who
was the defense attache in Paris at the
time the only person that Nixon trusted
come fly back come back to work now
Kissinger had a bunch of communication
circuits installed in the sit room that
he could use and they were there when I
got there one it was a button on my
phone set that went to the Israeli
embassy and one to the Soviet embassy
and I
I picked it up and pushed the button and
to see who would answer because I
thought it was a horrible security
breach and and indeed one and someone
answered with a Slavic accent I don't
know what he said the other one nobody
answered I had him removed immediately
but I got a great story about one of
them about the Israeli button during the
1973 war arab-israeli war Ariel Sharon
was pushing across the Sinai with his
tanks pushing hard towards the AP of
Egypt and Kissinger didn't want Sadat's
government undercut because he needed
him for post-war peace process and he
was on the horn to the Israeli embassy
yelling at the Israeli ambassador get
him to call Google go to my ear to have
him her stops cherone and got so
exasperated talking to this man he
finally yelled Jesus Christ don't you
know how important this is
but MacFarlane was in the room and he
said there was a deathly bit of silence
just then and then Henry said yes so bud
said well you gotta ask Henry what the
other end of the conversation was
happened so when I was in New York he
starts to laugh he said that the Israeli
ambassador said something to the effect
of Henry my government might be more
persuaded to your argument if you invoke
the name of a different prophet so
that's the sort of thing that can happen
down there through these dedicated
select communications and we try not to
talk about it too much because if you
don't have one to your country you're
mad because somebody else does excuse me
this is on the other end of the duty
officer area where the analysts work
there's usually someone that comes in
about midnight and helps put together
the morning summary and another analyst
comes in about 8:00 in the morning helps
to be good to put together the evening
summary and those are the two of the
four windows that you that you saw
earlier in the exterior and the
computers are better now than they used
to be but in fact now they
to several processors using the same
terminal and you can switch from the
internet over to processing classified
information the two most important
sources of breaking information in the
White House Situation Room today are the
cable news industry CNN Fox MSNBC and
the Internet in this day of an open
society they're less dependent upon
classified reporting they still get a
lot and they have to integrate them all
the CI sends down their morning summary
and state gives the president there's in
the Pentagon but each institution has
its own vision about the world in the
sit room is where things kind of come
together and things get integrated now
the conference room itself catches most
everyone's imagination this is Johnson
during the Vietnam War Tet Offensive in
the conference room and this is his
famous model of Khe Sanh and a lot of
people ridiculed him from micromanaging
the war but his concerns were that if he
ordered the wrong bombing attack the
Soviet Union of the Chinese would come
into the war and we'd have World War 3
and so he agonized over this and if you
ever want to read a really insightful
biography there's lots of them but I
like Doren Doris Kearns Goodwin book
about how he acted during the war
because she got into his head and it was
a fascinating story that model still in
the basement of the Johnson library I
found it covered with dust
this is his press secretary over here
Walt Rostow who died a couple weeks ago
his national security adviser and he
didn't want caisson that this combat
base in the northern part of South
Vietnam to become another as he called
it Dinh being field which is when the
French lost a big battle to the
Vietnamese in 1954 and it was not just a
battle it's a metaphor for a Western
country doing badly in Asia this is what
the conference room looked like in
Carter's time it had been remodeled by
that time it's essentially the same
configuration and is now a little
different table different chairs
sir this was during Reagan's second term
during the hijacking of a TWA aircraft
and the in the Mideast 1985 TW 847
notice the name plates I want to come
back to that later but Reagan surrounded
himself with people that he was
comfortable with in the sit room and he
was quite comfortable and coming down
there and meeting during crises and this
is clearly on a weekend you can tell by
his dress he never wore anything but a
suit and tie during the week this is
what the place looked like in 1989 the
same table and chairs you can see
there's not much room for the back
benchers in fact many people use the
smallness of the conference room to
exclude people oh sorry can't come in
not enough room for you and just keep
the principles down there and keep all
the hangers-on out of the way that door
in the back went into the main entrance
to the Situation Room complex
this is Clinton's first term I had
trouble getting photos because all of
his stuff is embargoed until his library
opens up but I got this from a friend of
mine who's back there briefing Clinton
who was a Navy admiral that was the
intelligence officer for the Joint
Chiefs at the time this had something to
do with the Balkans again on the weekend
everybody's in casual dress nametags
don't these people know who they are you
know they meet every week why do you
need a nametag is that you mr. president
it's just a custom in the sit room in it
everyone has a nametag Madeleine
Albright Tony Lake Warren Christopher
Secretary of State shalikashvili the
chairman over there in the windbreaker
Al Gore in the corner okay this is a
little more formal meeting you can tell
us during the week everybody's dressed
up but by 1997-98 they had refurbished
the conference room and turned the table
around that door back in the corner goes
into the area where the duty officers
are and this is the table and the chairs
that are there now I believe it's it's
the same paneling you can see there's a
TV a big monitor that's about all they
have in the way of displays there there
are no flashing lights and battleships
and planes and all that he doesn't need
it
they have all that at the Pentagon and
they can beam that across the river onto
that TV if he has to have it but it's
really it's still the Paper Chase you
can tell now the president has three
nametags there but I really think they
belong to sandy Berger and Al Gore as
well as the president yes sir this is
the set of the Situation Room on NBC's
the West Wing and I talked to the guy
that designed the set at Warner Brothers
and he got some pictures from the
Johnson administration and used them as
a guide but he brought the ceiling down
made a little darker because it's more
dramatic that way and you can see it's a
little bigger a little more stuff but of
all the situations that have been
created by Hollywood this comes the
closest to the real thing you've just
seen the pictures
of what it looks like but they were
quite nice aaron sorkin asked me if her
copy the book maybe we'll get some
stories working I don't know we'll have
to wait and see now the situation room
has been the site of a lot of crises and
a lot of wars and and and there's gonna
be a little action down there in the
next few days over the years there have
been plenty of presidents that have been
down there in crisis this is Lyndon
Johnson in 1967 arab-israeli war in the
reason why he was down there was that
there was a good bit of tension between
the Soviet Union in the u.s. at that
point would the war widen to include the
primary sponsors of the two combatants
the Arabs and Israelis during that six
days Johnson and his people exchanged 21
messages with the Soviet Union over the
hotline it was the most it had ever been
used the Moscow hotline is not a red
telephone and it has never has been and
never will be because nobody trusts
themselves to say the right words under
crisis you always want to type out a
message and in the early days it was a
teletype now it's a computer and a fax
but the Soviets were afraid that we
would widen the war in vice versa so
they had four or five exchanges a day
and the reason why I Johnson stayed down
there was because there was just so much
to do they would get a message in they
all sit around and try to figure out how
to answer it and he spent so much time
down there that he had his chair brought
down for the Oval Office and Lady Bird
would bring in breakfast and she told me
one time that she went to the White
House mess they cooked up bacon and eggs
for everybody came in and didn't realize
so many people were there she was still
in her jammies in her in her nightgown
in her room
it was so surprised that all these men
were still down here
you may remember Reagan's assassination
attempt there was chaos around the White
House because these people didn't know
how big the problem was other people
were targeted they didn't know whether
the president was gonna live and there
a good bit of confusion down there some
of you may remember that Al Haig said he
was in charge he got a little confused
about the presidential succession and he
was a little farther down than maybe he
thought he was but the reason why I did
that was that Larry speaks to press
secretary was asked upstairs in the
press room who was in charge the vice
president was out of town the
president's the hospital and speaks his
I'm not sure well that was the worst
thing you could say at the time and Haig
realized that so we weren't running
upstairs little out of breath
grabs the podium and say I'm in charge
well everybody just lampooned him just
drilled him for that but what he was
trying to do was calm everybody down so
there's no problem somebody's in charge
and I had a nice conversation with him
about that he spent a whole chapter in
his memoir trying to explain why he said
that
speaking of crises this was at 9/11 the
Secret Service evacuated the White House
except the duty officers in the sitting
room stayed there everyone else that was
left went down to the East Wing basement
in an old bomb shelter left over from
World War two called the President's
Emergency Operations Center the peoc and
that's where case of Cheney rise carry
news and others stayed until they
figured out what was going on the
president would remember was flying
around the country and he was using that
video teleconferencing capability to
stay in touch in fact here's a shot of
Camp David
pull it over a little bit Joe there you
go of the president talking to his
advisors via the video teleconferencing
and that piece of furniture there has
for conference rooms that are tied into
the system at that point the upper left
is the sit room and then there's
probably State Department and all that
sort of stuff so he's quite comfortable
using that Reagan never set foot into
that room those people in that
generation liked to sit down in person
and talk but the first Bush
administration started to use it and in
the Clinton's and now everybody uses
that capability in fact when the Clinton
team was in South America on a trip
it was during the World Series in Jim
Steinberg who was the deputy national
security adviser to sandy Berger was
with the president and they were trying
to figure out how how to follow that
World Series so they piped the World
Series feed through the video
teleconferencing system and they all sat
around their hotel room watching the
what's in the World Series game the
people that worked there are on loan
from other agencies CIA the National
Agency State Department when I got there
recruited officers from each service so
that we could have five watts teams of
three people each and the reason why
they borrow them is so that you can send
them back if there's a problem it's hard
to get rid of somebody that's a sign
they're like you send down deep
bureaucratic roots it also gets the
people a chance to broaden their horizon
they go back much smarter than they were
when they got there I'd show this Bush
just stopped in all the time say hello
get a picture but this was our comms
technician for that team and then she
was a junior duty officer he was a
junior duty officer senior duty officer
guy in the back was one of the analysts
and then that's me when I looked a
little younger this guy right here was
on watch the night that Ali North and
fawn hall started shredding their
material when it hit the fan during the
iran-contra affair they sort of burned
out a burying in their shredder and they
came over to the sitting room and used
ours it was pretty good shredder because
once you get through it's just like
angel hair pasta big plastic bag we tied
it up threw it in the dumpster I got a
call from CIA a few weeks later and they
asked me if I knew about one of their
employees selling shredded White House
documents I said no I don't know
anything about that turns out that he
recognized the significance of what he
was seeing
and took the bag home with him and got
together with his family and started
selling the shredded documents just like
you so you buy the shredded dollar bills
at the beer Engraving it was shredded
contre documents I never saw him again
it just never came back okay but they're
all young people relative professionals
you can't be old and work 12 hour shifts
it's just that it doesn't go together
now the White House Situation Room is
the White House help desk everything
that isn't taken care of by somebody
else gets to the White House sit room
somehow this is buddy
Clinton's dog and buddy got a little
rambunctious from time to time in the
White and the president stewards would
bring him down to the sit room and they
would take care of him until he calmed
down well the president was busy with
something and this is Tony Campanella
one of the duty officers in the late 80s
with his picture of Buddy and he would
sit there like any good Labrador on the
on somebody's feet and curl up and go to
sleep while they were processing
information in the in the sit room and
lastly the conference room gets used for
some oddball things from time to time
this was a pumpkin carving contest
during the Carter Administration with
Brzezinski as the judge and so everybody
all got dressed it's at that point it
just becomes a conference room just like
anybody else's conference room it's not
not that special this was a birthday of
blood McFarlane and John Poindexter the
guys that I worked for Reagan came down
blew out the candles
that's Jame Baker in the back this is
Bill Clark he was a communications
technician that worked in the White
House for years and he had the most
amazing capability to find a photo op
and get in it he was always in a picture
now Harry is a sergeant in the Air Force
having a glass of champagne for the
president and and and then he would get
the photo a copy of the photo and take
it home
and then when I was there we had a
Thanksgiving dinner because everybody
was away from their families and we just
did yeah yeah yeah and the funny thing
is the woman over on the right next to
me with the red sweater had baked the
turkey at home and brought it in in the
afternoon and the sit room duty officers
can park on the White House grounds on
weekends and on holidays usually they're
out on the ellipse and she had to stop
the Secret Service had to examine the
car and they have dogs and she gets out
of the car the dogs get a little sniff
of the turkey and they're scrambling to
get into the car and it was it's just a
mess she just sort of grabbed it and
went running in to the west wing trying
to hold on to her turkey before the dogs
got it so that's it for pictures and my
presentation if you have any questions
I'd be happy to try to answer them
there's two entrances to it right you
have to get past an armed Secret Service
Officer uniformed division as soon as
you come in to the ground floor the West
Wing after that the doors are protected
by cipher locks and you have to know the
combination to get in and there are our
television cameras built into the
woodwork in fact right after Bush became
president bush senior one weekend it
didn't have much to do and he came down
there and knocked on the door because he
wanted to find out what was going on and
someone looked in the monitor connected
to the cameras it's the president and
somebody said well let him in and he
said do you mind if I come in I don't
have anything to do and I thought I
might just talk to you guys so once you
have a White House badge
a West Wing or a mansion badge not an
across the street badge you can walk
around in there you can't get in unless
you know the cypher number but even if
you don't know the syphon number you're
really not gonna learn much in the sit
room Aldrich Ames walked through when he
was spying for the Soviets and he was
taken to lunch by a friend of mine who
was the state department officer who
didn't know that Ames was a spy
they had met each other in Mexico City
had lunched in the mess and took Ames
through we got a tour of the sit room
walked out I'm sure he didn't learn
anything now he probably told the KGB I
was in the sit room today and it you
maybe got in a raise a Kissinger took
Anatoly Dobrynin the longtime Soviet
ambassador of abortion and right in to
where the duty officers were showed him
everything it was going on and I said
well why'd you do that and he said to
enhance his stock back in Moscow I have
access to the White House I was in the
Situation Room trust me to talk to
Kissinger so the Clintons it was like a
jacksonian democracy everybody came in
went I mean the Friends of Bill the
movie stars were all in the citroen the
minute the bushes came in that was over
there much more restrictive about who
gets in down there
sir they go in a severe crisis to
protect continuity of government I can't
comment on that because it's pretty
sensitive in the old days East Wing bomb
shelter during the heights of the Cold
War the idea was get the president out
of the White House out of town on the
helo get him in the National airborne
command center and do business away from
the White House that program is still in
force
I presume because Dick Cheney went to an
undisclosed location but it's probably
one of the more sensitive things in
government and I just don't want to tell
everything I know about it we were not
involved with a big war the football
nuclear release codes that's the
province of the White House military
office and when I was there I never
believed that Soviets had the capability
to strike from the blue anyway without
some foreknowledge of it so we never
paid any attention to it
the real world was in the sit room this
this possibility of a surprise nuclear
attack was handled by the military aides
and they had the football I never saw
what was inside of it sir how much
interaction is there between the people
who are in the Situation Room and the
people who are at the Pentagon
a good deal good deal and there's a lot
of information goes back and forth it's
tough because the people in Pentagon
don't want to tell the White House
anything unless the secretary defense
okay's it there's a big political
problem over there so I pick up the
phone and talk to the head of the
National Military Command Center nimac
yeah NMCC what about so and so what
about this plane what happened to this
what happened to that I'm sorry I can't
tell you they're very reluctant but they
don't understand that the president just
came down there and said what about this
plane and they don't understand the
pressures you have to answer questions
and so we developed a lot of
back-channel ways to get information I
being a naval officer would call the
intelligence center the Navy's
intelligence plot and get what I needed
because I couldn't get it from the
e-ring of the Pentagon we didn't we
weren't contemptuous of them we just had
demands we had to meet for remember when
Scott O'Grady was shot down in the
Balkans the Air Force guy the sit room
was getting more information from the
intelligence community than the Pentagon
had and Tony Lake would call Secretary
of Defense what do you guys know and
then tell him what he knew that he got
from the sit room and it was always
better than what they could get from the
Pentagon and we never wore our uniforms
and we never told him our rank because
if we did some general would run right
over me and so it was just Mike bond
from the sit room and they generally
understood during the 91 Gulf War they
couldn't follow the battle plans because
no one would tell them what we were
trying to do the sit room was in the
dark but they were kept getting
questions how's it going what are we
doing and so finally : Powell took pity
on everybody and accidentally left a map
and a briefing folder for the duty
officers to get smart on and then they
were able to keep up with what was going
on but it's a very tenuous problem for
the duty officers because they're
generally generate junior people and
they're having to go back to their home
agencies and demand information and they
can get themselves in trouble and so the
National Security Adviser tries to
protect them
because they're only doing what they're
told the only one exception to that and
his name was north oliver north he had
other agenda he was still trying to do
what he thought best but i if you listen
to him he handled the pentagon a little
differently than the rest of us is that
sort of what you were on the national
security staff yeah he and I were
classmates at the Naval War College and
we're next-door neighbors for years and
our families have grown up together and
then we became colleagues on the NSC
staff and he had one of the assignments
on that staff and he used the sitting
room a lot I was involved in the sale of
Iran's arms to Iran but not the support
to the Contras and therefore I didn't
get in too much trouble the FBI did come
in and clean out my safe and my desk and
I spent a lot of hours in front of Judge
Walsh trying to say that I didn't know
anything so it was a messy time for all
of us
during that around Contra affair but I
still stay close to John Poindexter I
think the world of him I think he was
trying to do the best he could under the
circumstances and he's an honorable man
you had a question
there's too much audio-visual stuff for
PowerPoint presentation of more routine
covering business is upstairs someplace
I take it messages for crisis now with
those large monitors in the sitting room
you can pump anything into it overhead
imagery CNN whatever anything digital
can go in there in the old days more
often than not it was somebody from the
Pentagon or State Department or CIA
would come over with a poster and put it
on an easel and talk from that in the
Reagan administration those men were
comfortable with that and as presidents
and staffs get younger the Clintons for
example they're more flexible in dealing
with that sort of thing
but you can do anything in the
conference room that you can do anywhere
else it but the emphasis not is not on
technology in that room all the money
goes in to the back end of the project
which is the processing the computers
the communications and all that that's
all high-tech state-of-the-art there's
just been no pressure to do anything
else in the conference room over the
years had there been it would be in the
fact that it's not means that nobody has
really wanted it anything else other we
talked about the Pentagon how many other
major action centers are there there's a
whole network of them in Washington and
of course around the world and in
1963-64 the head of the sit room created
the Washington area operations and
command center committee or something
like it's called the way Ock and they
sponsored the creation of secure
telephone systems so that they could all
talk during a crisis and they still do
if something happens somebody will
initiate a conference call and they'll
exchange information so they're the
sitting room is not watching for
Armageddon by themselves there are
people in town that are doing the same
thing and they coordinate and most
importantly they coordinate who they're
waking up because if the Pentagon wakes
up the Secretary of Defense and the
State Department doesn't wake up the
Secretary of State somebody will be
embarrassed in the morning so they try
to ratchet things up to the same level
who are you gonna wake up well I'm okay
well I better do that and all it's not
on purpose but it's sort of an ancillary
before they hang up they want to
coordinate a little bit because the last
thing you want to do is embarrass your
boss in the morning so there's a good
bit of coordination obviously the ones
that are important their state Pentagon
CIA NSA the intelligence agencies other
departments now have become involved
they were all other than the major ones
the second-tier agencies were just
creating those in the 80s when I left
so now it's externally developed and the
homeland security people have taken over
a lot of that stuff away from the
sitting room
there's never been a domestic sit room
people have tried to create some over
the years but it never worked the 1993
World Trade Center attack the domestic
side of the White House tried to manage
that and couldn't and so Tony like just
took it over and said I'll take care of
that for you infrastructure to build up
an information system for
decision-makers that was a big deal down
there and they worked hard on it and
they didn't have much trouble as many
people didn't it was a non-event in the
sit room you had a question
no sir in terms of the people who are in
attendance during some of the critical
meetings with the president in defending
the normal people who run the sit room
are their cabinet folks generally
involved with this or there's a
hierarchy of meetings or committees over
the past 15 20 years that sort of been
fairly common everything has a different
name but generally in the last two or
three administrations there's a
committee called the deputies committee
and as you would imagine there the
deputy heads of the cabinet agencies and
they get together and talk about
government options and issues and they
what's called tea up an issue for the
next level of consideration which is the
principal's committee and those are the
principal heads of the agencies
everybody except the president they then
consider options and come to conclusions
and make recommendations and then bring
the president into the decision-making
process into the meeting and that can be
in the sit room or it can be in the Oval
Office it can be a Camp David can be in
the family quarters or it can be by
video teleconference and where the
president has that meeting and who he
meets with is a function of his style
Nixon never went in the sit room during
the 73 war he would sit in his office
and send Al Haig back and forth to bring
him updates about what people were
talking about because he didn't want to
have a confrontation with somebody he
wanted a written recommendation Reagan
was comfortable coming down to those
meetings
Clinton would have them in the Oval
Office because he wanted everybody in
the meeting he wanted all these people
and they wouldn't fit in the sitting
room but the bottom line of this is
there is a there is a public relations
issue about where presidents meet during
crises if he meets in the Situation Room
that it could mean to some people that
he's worried that there's a crisis and
it needs managing if he meets in the
Oval Office or the Cabinet Room business
as usual everything's cool and you found
different approaches to that Brent
Scowcroft thought the president should
be President Bush in the sit room during
those things to show that he had a hand
on things
Tony Lake thought that Clinton should be
in the Oval Office for the obverse
reason business as usual
so there's meetings all day all the time
in the sit room but there is a hierarchy
of decision-making in crisis management
that goes up each time finally gets to
the president and how he handles those
meetings in where he has them as a
function to his style because it's not
all manic they don't all just go to the
sit room and something happens except
when the day Reagan was shot they didn't
know what else to do and they were those
men new to the job two months in office
they just felt comfortable going to the
sit room because it's everybody's
comfortable with it they know where it
is they know they'll get help
there'll be people there to be
communications hot coffee that sort of
thing sir
no I was not there then but I talked to
a lot of people that were in that room
and if you may remember dick Allen was
an escort advisor at the time he put a
tape recorder out and recorded the whole
sordid mess and then released it on the
20th anniversary of the assassination
attempt last year last year yeah and a
lot of people were embarrassed because
they didn't they didn't instill
confidence in you here was a seat most
senior people in the government and they
were confused didn't know who was in
charge and they would argue about things
but it worked out and in the end for
your time but where was the Kennedy XCOM
during the Cuban Missile Crisis he kept
him in the Oval Office generally
sitting-room was new wasn't that
comfortable
he had a gang of people so what would
happen is McGeorge Bundy in what amounts
to the deputies or and other people
would meet in the conference room but
when the XCOM met the Executive
Committee of the National Security
Council they would meet upstairs it was
sort of new to the presidency Johnson
went right down there he was used to it
by that time but I found a lot of good
records and a lot of good stories about
what was going on in the sit room during
that period
they are there minutes kept those oh
yeah yeah all of those deliberations are
part of the national security council
record-keeping and the sit room used to
be the repository for all those minutes
all the way back and there was a big
storage room with these big file
cabinets and all that sort of stuff and
in the 80s we shipped it all over across
the street over to the old EOB and where
it is now and we just it was got too
voluminous but they kept the records for
the National Security Council for years
down there in the sit room during a
meeting yes people take notes during
presidential phone calls people take
notes one last story then I'll get out
of your way we had a taping system that
we didn't use very often and when I was
there we did not tape any presidential
phone calls but there was someone on the
White House staff that told Bob Woodward
that we did and it was during the Iran
Contra affair and he's got a little
sniff of Nixon tapes secret White House
taping system and he wrote a front page
story in The Washington Post that
absolutely ruined my day sit room has
secret taping system Oliver North's it
will it uncover Oliver North's secret
enterprise and will it show culpability
by the President and dot it out of that
we had a shoebox full of old milk tapes
and occasionally we would use them from
time to time not presidential phone
calls and we'd tape over the old
conversation and then when we were done
we throw it back in this shoebox well
Bob Woodward exposed my shoebox and I
had I had to inventory it listened to
all the stuff tell let's see who was
left by that time Poindexter had been
fired I guess it was Frank Carlucci
the new NASA career advisor what was in
my shoebox and it was nothing but it
looked like he really had something
there for a while
Johnson taped a lot of his telephone
calls and I've gotten copies of his
conversations with the duty officers and
it's amazing insight into the man 11
o'clock at night ready to go to bed
picks up the phone what's going on what
about my boys 5:30 in the morning pick
up the phone what's going on what about
my boys interesting insight if you ever
had c-span played Johnson tapes over the
radio for year really fascinating stuff
but he was he was quite a character is
that it well thanks very much this was
fun thank you John nerve center inside
the White House Situation Room is
published by brassey's visit brassey's
ink.com for more information